all right the Sixers in this game
hitting 22 threp pointer 22 of 46 just
under 48% the season high for them I
mean it was
impressive it really was and we talked
about well you know if the Lakers could
somehow limit that but you got to give
this Philly team a lot of credit they
they've been clicking on all C cylinders
for the most part this year they've been
so good with sharing the basketball
embiid's added another dimension to his
game with his ability to facilitate
Maxi's been phenomenal so just a
complete total annihilation of the
Lakers who just didn't seem like they
wanted to be on the floor tonight it
didn't seem like it especially in the
first half you know Philly getting out
to a 25o lead and I think it took all
the Lakers had to just get the game back
into you know striking range at 13 14
and they just couldn't get over the hump
I mean anytime the Lakers made a run it
just seemed like Philly knocked down a
three or indeed got to the free throw
line and that was the story of tonight I
mean you're not going to win many ball
games allowing the opponent to shoot
47.8% from three especially when your
team doesn't shoots the three ball all
that well you know we thought maybe
going to that third quarter the Lakers
defense would kind of ramp up a little
bit but they gave up 30 in the third and
then 40 in the fourth I know some of the
starters were gone by then but still I
would say disappointing right from an LA
perspective as far as their defense
especially in that second half I think
so but as a team that has been playing
pretty well as of late if you're the
Lakers sometimes you got to just this up
to a long road trip and move on to the
next and I think you know this is a
tough stretch for a Lakers team you know
playing in Cleveland you know a couple
nights ago and then coming back on you
know playing a ready Philadelphia
76-year team so we'll see how they
bounce back because I know the motto
LeBron has had coming into the Lakers is
to avoid losing two in a row and so
let's see how they bounce back on the
road yeah and and listen give Philly a
lot of credit though only five turnovers
as well right so the way they were able
to move the the basketball tonight uh 33
assists they shot the three ball well MB
with a 30-point triple dub Maxi drops in
his 30 you got great uh performan that's
off your bench so just a complete
overall performance by the Sixers team
and and listen the Lakers obviously
didn't have it tonight they're still
trying to figure out when they can get
healthy uh darham I I know wants to have
an opportunity just to kind of see what
he has as a as a roster and then you can
start trying to cultivate your rotation
but tonight they did not look like a a
contender if you will they they looked
like a team that just was not ready to
compete and Philly just mauled them Joel
and be again 30 points 11 rebounds 11
assist of that first triple double of
the season for him he does that in three
quarters here he is with Taran
Hatcher all right Joel your first triple
double of the Season 311 and 11 but I
want to talk about those 11 assists
because it seems like you've made such a
point to really spread the production
around this season what's been different
for you in terms of being an assist guy
as well right now um you know you trying
to play winning basketball um you know
my teammates are wide open you know get
them easy shots uh just make the game
easy for myself um you know uh honestly
you know just seeing the game better so
I I don't think he something that I
never had before I think I've always had
it and uh you know and you know that's
just put me in you know position to make
it happen obviously a great shooting
night tonight for you and your teammates
22 threes amongst your team and you see
guys like Pat Beverly hitting from
downtown Marcus Morris it seemed like
you were going off when Mo bomba hit his
his three down there at the end what is
how much more fun is a game like this
where it feels like everything's falling
and everyone's getting involved uh that
better do it every night so man it's
good uh no but I'm proud of him we
playing you know we playing together we
having fun sharing the ball the ball is
moving uh you know we know what we got
to do but it's s it's he sa on defense
um and then you know once you get
stopped you able to you know get in
transition and you know get easy baskets
Joel congratulations on the win thank
you for the time thank
you g you mentioned this earlier just in
terms of his leadership and how do you
lead you dominate on the boards you
dominate scoring and you dominate
facilitating and embiid had himself a
triple double and I will say that it has
been a joy to watch post players and
Superstars realize that yes they can put
up 30 40 points a night but you need the
others you need the others to feel good
and to feel Rhythm uh to to get the the
wins in the playoffs and you're seeing
embiid do it on both sides of the floor
here ad spectacular move one twos it
embiid times it perfectly I just think
that he is
playing great basketball he's playing in
space 10 of 12 from the free throw line
tonight he's facilitating 11 assists and
I think you're on to something in terms
of he's averaging the highest career
assists that he's had in the season and
I know it's early but for his for his
career he's averaged 3.5 this season
he's averaging 6.2 and you know we
criticized yic last year for kind of
taking a step back not taking as many
shots getting others involved well
listen that led to a championship and I
think embiid is seeing the power in
making those around him better and he's
still going to eat he still got 30 still
leading the league he's still leading
the league and scoring so when you're
able to do that defenses don't know what
to do when you can pass score play
defense run the floor handle the ball in
the middle of the floor I just think
that he is out to a great start and it's
because of his leadership and his Poise
yeah the starters did their things so to
the bench 50 points for the Philly
bench